do you ever worry that your writing is
unclear whether you're writing an email
newsletter a script for a YouTube video
or a paper for publication expert
writers use writing to share their
knowledge and expertise but it really
doesn't matter how valuable your ideas
are because if you can't write clearly
your ideas will never make it off the
page and into the mind of the reader so
in today's video I'm going to give you
three reader focused writing tips that
you can use to improve your writing and
that helped my writing students achieve
results like these welcome back to
writer science the channel where we
explore the Art and Science of expert
writing if you're new here I'm William
and I'm an English Professor based in
South Korea and to understand the first
tip we first need to remember a game
that we used to play as kids you know
that game when you're in the backseat of
a car 8 years old your parents are
driving and you're about to go through a
tunnel what do you do well if you're
anything like me what you do here is
take in a big breath and try to hold it
until you get to the end of the tunnel
sometimes this was simple enough but
whenever the tunnel was long the game
got hard because the longer you sat
there the more impatient you'd get
hopelessly waiting for the car to reach
the end of the tunnel and it's starting
to seem like the car is slowing down and
you're starting to turn blue in panic
because you're not sure if you're going
to make it but you must make it so you
can catch your breath and inside you're
thinking oh my God hurry up already when
are we going to get
there well that feeling of anticipation
of hopelessly waiting for the arrival of
something important it happens a lot
when we read take a look at these two
sentences which one is easier to read a
detailed explanation of why readers find
it difficult to read sentences whose
grammatical subjects are overloaded is
given in this
video this video explains in detail why
readers find it difficult to read
sentences whose grammatical subjects are
overloaded if the second sentence seems
easier to read it's thanks to the
location of the verb the verb is like
the end of the tunnel it's the most
important part of the sentence because
it tells the reader what's going going
on and how all the other parts of the
sentence relate to each other so from
the start of the sentence readers are
kind of holding their breath eagerly
waiting for the arrival of the verb if
the verb occurs near the beginning of
the sentence like in sentence two then
it's like driving through a short tunnel
which is pretty easy but if the verb
occurs near the end of the sentence like
in sentence one then the reader has to
take a deeper breath and hold it for a
longer time and they're just dying to
get through everything that's front
loaded at the beginning of the sentence
readers like to get past the subject to
the verb as quickly as possible so the
first tip for writing clearly is to keep
your grammatical subject short but right
next to the subject is where we find the
second source of unclear writing and
when writers fail to control this their
writing becomes about as Lively and
active as a graveyard so if you don't
want your writing to feel dead then we
need to consider what happens when we
die your soul leaves your body and when
a dead body lurches around without a
soul it's called a zombie so see if you
can spot the zombies lurking around in
these sentences right here the
transformation of humans into zombies
was a result of the virus's mutation the
detection of movement in the shadows
signaled the presence of zombies nearby
the destruction of the quarantine Zone
allowed the zombies to infiltrate the
safe areas the problem with these
sentences is that the action which is
the sole of the verb has left its body
instead of the action being located in
the verb it's packed away in these noun
phrases I mean look at this first
sentence like humans aren't
transforming into zombies it's that
there is a transformation of humans
people aren't detecting movement a
movement is detected there is a
detection of movement the quarantine
Zone isn't destroyed there was a
destruction of the quarantine Zone these
verb ns are sometimes called Zombie
nouns because they suck the life out of
the verb they represent action not as an
active verb but as a lifeless noun the
verb is the Beating Heart of your
sentence readers look to the verb to
find out what's going on so when you're
editing your work it's really important
to make sure that the verb carries the
action of the sentence so now I'm going
to give you a threep formula that you
can use to fix zombie nouns but before
that here's a pro tip that you can use
for whenever you're out hunting for
zombie nouns they usually end in t i o n
m n t or e nce it doesn't account for
all of them but that's a really good
sign so the first step for fixing zombie
nouns is to find the action and put it
back where it belongs into the verb so
in this first case we have
transformation that would be
transform what other action is there of
humans into zombies was the result of
the viruses mutation so that would be
mutate and result we might want to use
the verb cause in the second case the
detection well that would be detect the
detection of movement that would be move
or moving and the Shadows signal the
presence that would be the verb to be so
we don't need that of zombies nearby and
the last one the destruction of the
quarantine Zone allowed the zombies to
infiltrate the safe areas well that's
going to be destruction destroy and
infiltrate well infiltrate is infiltrate
but here it is in a non-finite verb so
we might try to put that back into the
the seat of the verb after we've
identified the actions and put them into
verbs we now need to decide which
character performs the action of those
verbs because we're going to put those
characters into the subject position so
when I look at the verb transform I
asked myself what transformed humans
transforms and then what mutated well
the virus mutated so we have humans
trans transforming and viruses mutating
and what did the humans transform into
the humans transformed into zombies so
in the second sentence we have detect
and move so who detected well the
detection of movement in the shadows
signal the presence of zombies so it
must be humans humans detected and what
was moving well movement in the shadows
it must have been zombies moving and
Destroy well we don't exactly know who
did the destroying but we can use the
passive voice here to say that the
quarantine Zone was destroyed and who
did the infiltrating well the zombies
did the infiltrating that's already
there we can leave it but we want to use
this as a finite verb so zombies
infiltrated and what did they infiltrate
they infiltrated the safe areas all
right so now we've broken up our zombie
nouns into Clauses and now we have to
think what is the proper relationship in
the sentence among these Clauses so in
this first one we have two Clauses which
have a relationship of cause and effect
so the virus mutating causes humans to
transform into zombies so we'll make
this our main clause and we will turn
this one into the effect of that clause
which cause the humans to transform into
zombies but actually because these are
in a relationship of cause and effect
what we can do is just strike out this
middle uh pronoun and turn this verb
into an in so it becomes the virus
mutated comma causing the humans to
transform into zombies now in the second
sentence I think the main clause for me
is going to be detected the humans
detected what their presence nearby but
the zombies moved let's keep movement in
a verb so we can say as the zombies
moved the humans detected their presence
nearby and again in this last one we
have a relationship of cause an effect
the quarantine Zone was destroyed that's
the cause the effect is the zombies
infiltrated so we can say since the
quarantine Zone was destroyed comma the
zombies and the original sentence was
about how this allowed the zombies to
infiltrate so we can capture that with
the modal verb could so since the
quarantine Zone was destroyed the
zombies could Infiltrate The safe areas
so just like that if you don't want your
writing to seem like a visit with the
dead then be sure to put the action of
your sentence in the verb now those
first two points were about the
structure of individual sentences but
it's not enough to have short subjects
and action-packed verbs we also need to
make sure that when we put these
sentences together they flow but what do
we mean when we talk about writing that
flows see a sentence is kind of like a
piece of wood in one of those 3D cube
puzzles readers don't look at the
individual pieces they also want to know
how those pieces link up to form a
single unit of discourse the reader
needs to be able to see how that piece
Works within the pattern of the hole
here's a paragraph in which some but not
all of the sentences flow well together
see if you can spot the one that breaks
the flow the properties of lightness
strength and resistance to corrosion
make aluminum one of the most versatile
industrial materials first ly aluminum
is one of the lightest metals that has
ever been used today numerous products
from cans to Medical appliances to
airplanes use it due to the need for
lightweight yet strong materials in
these products aluminum is often the
Preferred Choice did you spot the
sentence that breaks the flow if you ask
me it's this one right here the third
sentence what is it about the other
sentences that seem to flow so well and
what is it about this one that breaks
the flow well the answer Li in the way
that each sentence organizes its
information notice how at the beginning
of this sentence introduces properties
and ends with aluminum and materials and
then this sentence begins with aluminum
and ends on materials that are being
used but then this sentence introduces
this new idea numerous products just
like a swimmer doing laps uses the edge
of a pool to push off and Propel forward
sentences that flow well maintain their
momentum by pushing off each other the
start of one sentence doesn't introduce
a brand new topic as it does here
instead it picks up where the last one
left off this pattern of organization is
known as old to new old information at
the start of the sentence new
information at the end because when the
last few words of a sentence sets up the
start of the next one the reader moves
easily from one idea to the next so to
make these sentences flow all we need to
do is rearrange the information so that
the old information aluminum which is
represented here by the pronoun it
begins at the beginning of the sentence
and this new information numerous
products occurs at the end of the
sentence so that becomes today aluminum
is used by many products so when we
insert that back into the main paragraph
it becomes today it is used by many
products from cans to Medical appliances
to airplanes and that's fantastic not
only because aluminum links up back to
this sentence but also even the verb
links back to the end of this sentence
so use and use are kind of pushing off
each other and then we introduce new
products at the end of the sentence and
that pushes forward into the next
sentence which talks about these
products the point here is that clear
writing flows and if you want your
writing to flow then all you have to do
is begin sentences with old information
and end them with new information
because when your sentences flow your
reader can experience flow which is that
wonderful feeling of losing yourself
that is the Hallmark of good writing and
that's the key to good writing an
obsessive Focus not on grammar rules but
on the reader so if you want to learn
some other reader focused writing tips
then you need to check out this video
right here because it's going to let you
in on some of the genius writing secrets
that nval roant uses every time he
writes something important so be sure to
go check it out